i wanted to talk about the four
different types of dangerous personality
types have you guys read uh joe
navarro's book dangerous personalities
twice
oh we have we have a captive audience
and moth i see your head nodding you've
got it jared did you get a chance to go
through it
no i haven't i'll check it out though i
am familiar with them because you know
we're we're all in the game in our own
prospective regard and you do come
across them it's yeah so let's talk
about you know the dangerous personality
types and i don't want to keep it narrow
to just you know like the ladies because
i mean there are a lot of douchebag
dudes out there that i've dealt with
over the years that you gotta
try to identify as quickly as possible
and these are really just the dark triad
traits but he adds an extra one on um
which were the four traits again i
haven't it's it's been a couple years
since i read his book so number
key idea oh that's a key idea let's see
the types he's got here tid and
narcissistic
emotionally paranoid personalities
unstable yeah those are the ones that's
what it is it's narcissism it's
emotionally
predatory and uh paranoid
yeah um so
i thought this was organized in a
different article i got the wrong one
then my bad anyway um
so
dangerous personalities can you guys
maybe like
take a couple of minutes and spill some
personal experience on
people that you've interacted with over
the years well not not people like i
don't want to hear 20 different stories
from everybody but like one story that
stands out where you dealt with a
dangerous personality whether it was a
dude or a chick
and
you not paying attention red flags or
what they were telling you when you were
dealing with them cause you know insert
havoc like but just distill it down like
i want to sanitize it i don't want like
10 minute explanations here so um 50
shades i'll let you go first you have a
story for us yeah see where maf is
sitting right now yeah about four blocks
from there i had to steal my car back
from a luxury apartment building i had
to go like james bond with rob and steal
my car out of the building because of a
cray-cray unstable and you know i
i ignored red flags somebody was hyper
nice to begin with pedestalized me
everything dude
you know everything was great about me
and and
all i done was cross one line and i i
was dirt on her shoe and literally had
to sneak in and get my car out of the
underground parking garage okay and and
why did you ignore the red flags like
what were the red flags that you saw
again again extremely nice way over the
top nice and love bombing you know
everything that is in that book
and
the four you know the four dangerous
personalities that he lists it's it's
they're
it's one of the best books you've
recommended
as i said earlier over we we tend to
over complicate stuff when we should
just keep it simple
i should be able to get this guy on a
podcast like if i reach out to him
i should be able to get him on because
he's got some really good insight i mean
i when i was listening to the book there
were so many times where i was like oh
my god that's you know so and so or it's
like you know you get to like another
segment of the book
it's like that's so you know it just
resonates so strong because he like hits
it so hard but
um yeah i mean you don't listen to it
you could end up like 50 shades and have
to go steal your car back from how did
she lock it up by the way like how did
she end up with it in my possession
where you had to seal it back
i was a guest in the building for the
weekend so i parked it in the
underground parking garage and
she wanted a situation where
she wanted me to come back and apologize
and was going to let me have it
you know like laughs at me for being the
whatever i am what did you do to offend
her so badly that she wanted to steal
your car
went outraging with the guys and you
never came home
yeah
you went out with the boys and then she
took your car hostage
yeah and then
were you there for this muff
no no
okay so then bert was out right yeah he
was he pulled up outside and his car
laughing while i went in and being my
personality i knew the doorman of the
building he's like hey irish man i said
yeah hey man let me in i'm just going
downstairs and went and jumped to my car
and skidded out of the garage just like
a bomb movie
nice
nice a little bit of charisma pays off
doesn't it
yep moth what do you got for us buddy
what's your story
well this one was lucky that um this
happened a little bit later after it was
already red pill so i was able to and i
already read the book by joe navarro so
i was able to kind of see the warning
signs very early but i was on a trip
with a handful of guys
more than a handful maybe it was about
you know it was kind of like a men's
retreat
um it wasn't involved with anything you
know one percent or or your community
but uh we had a moment where you know
come to the end of the trip uh everyone
kind of sits around and shares their
experiences and what they've got out of
the week or the weekend or whatever it
might be and this guy was actually a
local so he didn't much participate in
the activities but he would show up to
this and so we kind of gave him the
floor and gave him a couple of minutes
and from his tone his behavior his body
language the way he even moved his hands
when he spoke and even kind of like his
eyes as they sort of darted around the
room uh super super uncomfortable i had
multiple guys come up to me after the
fact that say hey look if this person
were to come on another trip again that
we were to do if he's gonna be a part of
this i would not feel
physically safe or i would not feel
like i would want to be around this
person in any sort of environment where
guns were involved or anything that
would be potentially dangerous
uh so you there there are things that
you could i would i would call that you
know emotionally unstable everything he
said was just said with a certain level
of vitriol and venom and you could feel
the anger coming off of him uh and it
was
some some guy
some guy made a joke i can't remember
exactly what it was but it's like
he was talking a lot about how he was
you know not great with women and how he
had not gotten laid in a long time and
somebody during it actually texted me
and said this guy's like if charles
manson was bad with chicks
if that's kind of what it's like um so
you know we had some conversations with
the guy we cut we sort of said hey we're
gonna kindly ask you not to return to
this sort of thing and uh it didn't
quite get ugly and that was great uh
cooler heads prevailed eventually but uh
luckily nobody was hurt or nothing
really happened but you could spot the
warning signs right away
yeah um
jaren you got a
a crazy dangerous personality type story
i do i posted about her before my my bpd
chick i know in uh the top one percent
forum every now and then the term bpd or
like the narcissistic personality
disorder comes up and i've alluded to
mine a couple of times she was a girl so
i'm in mexico right now i went to
college down here like 15 got 17 years
ago actually i'm getting older and she
went to university with me there and
then fast forward whatever many years it
was i was living in california before
this in san diego so she somehow made it
san diego too she reached out to me
tracked me down to like hey you know
you're a guy from university we never
really knew each other but
started hanging out started dating um
and immediately the love bombing like oh
my god she'd say things like you're a
greek god you're like a statue and i'm
even in my head
i should have known better because i'm
like that's weird like no one's ever
told me that before that's something you
it felt nice like it feeds your ego uh
but in my head i was like all right
that's kind of weird you know what
let me just stop you there for a second
because that's a really really important
point when
women act completely unconventional from
the norm and they love bomb you big time
like just pray like you're a greek god
like look at you like you're an adonis
uh you're the best sex i ever had like
okay let's be honest i mean we've all
heard that at some point but
you get the point
yeah i know yeah like like throwing
throwing hardcore praise and admiration
i think that's if i'm not mistaking
that's one of the key uh
signs of somebody with a borderline
personality disorder and then they tend
to go hot to cold like was this a hot
cold exchange for you
yeah she loved balmy at first i'd say
probably the first couple of weeks or so
um and then it and then it progressively
got a little worse and it it becomes an
addiction because you want to get back
to that point you're like all right like
if i just get like
you want to hear it again it is
yeah it's like if if i just do what it
is i need to do i can keep doing that
but they're really good they gaslight
you too
which they'll say like oh the sky's blue
you're like oh yeah it's a beautiful day
the sky is blue and they're like what
are you talking about the sky is gray
it's kind of like our mainstream media
does now uh
i i i i won't go too much detail there
but where they'll say things that are
obviously
not true and you're like well what's
going on eventually start questioning
yourself like am i am i crazy here like
what the hell um
and then
it it slowly degraded it got worse and
worse for behavior like one day i think
back when i used to clean my own houses
i was like cleaning the bathroom or
something and she bought like a little
seashell like soap holder that we put
next to the sink so i put it down below
the sink because i want to clear off the
counters and let them dry and not leave
water spots or whatever
pretty innocuous pretty minor detail she
came and flipped out like to the point
she like threw her arms out and she's
like
and she'd always she always yelled my
name too she she was a mexican girl so
she'd always be like
and my friends in san diego still make
fun of me like if we show up in public
somewhere and i can't quite see them
they're like
and uh
so this chick was
and i was like all right there's
something up with her like it's
definitely not me it got worse like we
had a skunk in the yard for a while and
i was like oh well california we'll call
someone here to come get it and then
after a couple days i'm like hey flora
that skunk must have left let me get you
to the point
yeah yeah yeah so she told me she told
me she murdered this skunk and at that
point all right all right this girl's
nuts and then she got really into like
this was in the jody area
she murdered a skunk
oh she poisoned him
which most most girls don't poison a
skunk or animals in general right yeah
like normally like they'll let animal
control come and get them this is the
end this is the kind of chick when you
come home there's a couple of bunnies
boiling in your potter there's a horse's
head in your bed when you wake up in the
morning
rich then it needs to be darn there
needs to be an entire show on your skunk
murderer
it's funny i haven't told the story in
so long it is funny thinking about it
now it's ridiculous dude i've heard some
crazy [ __ ] but not a skunk murderer yeah
i was like look what happened to this
guy she's like oh i poisoned him i'm
like what and
i thought she was i actually i think i
remember back i think she was full of
crap like okay whatever like animal
patrol must have came and gotten them um
and then eventually the jody arias thing
was going on that was like the big
cultural talk kind of like this amber
hurt thing to bring it all home and then
she started getting really really into
that eventually at one point my passport
disappeared and then i started getting
like the heebie jeebies she started
telling me like oh things like you don't
know who i know and if you don't treat
me right you know
i'm like all right we're done how many
months or weeks in was that like like
how long did you date this one for it
didn't take too long it was like three
or four months like it started off real
good and then it went downhill pretty
quick let me
let me share a couple certain stories so
very very short dating experience with
this chick saw her like two or three
times tops
i mean like the only reason why i kept
seeing her after i found out she was
crazy because she's hot i'm like you
know let's just keep going we'll see
where this goes right let's see how
crazy this [ __ ] really is
i'm on the very first date that i met
her
a couple coffees go for a stroll
shoot you know shoot the [ __ ] and she
goes
have you ever been in the back of a cop
car and i'm like that's a totally random
question to ask somebody on a first date
for out of no [ __ ] wear right and i
was like wait
have you ever been in the back of a cop
car and that's when she started spilling
the beans right on her little past
history with her ex-boyfriend
like fish fighting weren't they like
well what a woman does in her past is
generally going to happen you know in
the future right and she'll bring it out
of you even if you're not a violent guy
yeah i started getting those urges like
like i wanted to like hang on a sec so
she started telling the story about how
you know she ended up in the back of a
cop car because she went to go
to her boyfriend's house and he didn't
want her to come in so he locked the
door and then she proceeded to pick up
like he had firewood stacked at the side
of his house and she'd pick up a log and
start whipping it at the door
a couple of them went through the window
so shot in the front class of the house
he calls the cops she's in the back of
the cop car
this check proceeded to blow up my phone
for like two days after that okay
like
like red flags
the random uh dude that's like on the
reddit thing going my girlfriend's going
to vegas and talking to guys and texting
them is everything okay like that nerd
that's that's a typical guy that'll just
completely ignore that and they'll
accept the fact that you know he's with
a complete
nightmare and he's going to invite more
problems and chaos into his life
all you have to do is get good at
finance spotting that and you have a
much better experience with women am i
not correct here guys or am i wrong i
mean tell me if i'm wrong
no that book that book you recommended
rich was it it was a big eye-opener for
me and it allowed me to call
girls that i would not of color cut out
like um i think i told them after story
i hooked up with a former fitness
instructor like 22 years ago in new york
and we circled back and we got in touch
with each other you guys know what i
like the banter that i do and i sent her
the picture of you guys to see me in
miami dressed like you know a cuban drug
dealer or something you know i went over
the top but you know it's it's a cool
pic and i sent her that and what this
girl now was texting me for like a week
two weeks
you know we were flirting we were doing
all this stuff and back and forth and we
were supposed to meet on a friday
at a winery and this was a wednesday and
we started texting back before they sent
her that picture
and within two or three texts she
spiraled into projecting every type of
crazy personality onto me that i was a
narcissist i was a control freak i was a
while and in the past if i hadn't become
part of this group or become aware i
would have tried to go oh no no i'm this
i'm that and i would have apologized my
way out of it instead i just went block
delete gone yep
simple guys it's very very simple as
soon as you identify a dangerous check
you move on the only guys that tolerate
it are those with little to no options
when you have more options when your smv
is higher when you're a higher value guy
you're going to throw away
nightmares and not invite them into your
life to create the chaos that they that
they will inevitably bring it's going to
happen okay dude you're talking to a
chick and she's like you ever been in
the back of a cop car and she's like
well i have and here's why it's like
okay you know right then and there it's
like
no no more date like maybe
if you want to go to a crazy place go to
friends with benefits but like nothing
more that's it distance distance lots of
it too
um and
one thing to note on that is um as you
get better at your game like i've
stepped back and noticed these types of
girls don't even come onto my radar
anymore so it could be a thing of like
me projecting a part of me that pushes
them away or i think it's more so they
it's kind of like any sort of victimizer
criminal or anything they go after an
easy target like the house that's
unlocked and there's no guard dogs and
lights are on like inviting them to come
in like i think guys do a lot of the
same thing especially when you're in
like a like a down phase in your life or
you're maybe not where you want to be
you make yourself a mark whereas now um
i've noticed that those types of
personalities don't even really come
onto my radar every now and then like if
it's like a quick hookup or something
something my head would be like oh
there's something off of this girl but
if i'm not going to see her again like
it never gets to that point anymore and
yeah
there's something going on yeah exactly
that's a red flag guys that's that's a
red flag hey guys i really hope that you
enjoyed that short clip if you did
consider supporting the creation of
content by checking out my supplement
line pinned in the top comment below of
this video in the comments there's a
link to the unpluggedalpha.com forward
slash shop when you click through you'll
be able to land over here and the entire
lineup is broken down by category that
it performs best in estrogen metabolism
fat burning your foundational essentials
for health immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model where regular shipments will be
sent over to you on a regular basis and
that gives you a little bit of a
discount and your supplement facts are
always broken down over here thanks for
watching i hope you guys have an awesome
day and again check out that link it's
pinned in the top comment below in this
video peace out
you